uh this morning i was browsing the david
pakman show
subreddit where nearly 30 000 of our
viewers and listeners are now subscribed
you can find the subreddit at
davidpakman.com
reddit that's r-e-d-d-i-t very
interesting post this morning
um about how the actual effective tax
rate
for the bottom eighty percent of people
is actually higher in texas than in
california
there's been a big movement lately uh
including
in the context of covid people wanting
more freedom and particularly with the
recent news that
texas republican governor greg abbott is
ending
all coveted guidelines ending mass
mandates opening everything wide open
in texas there's been this idea for a
while and it's been both
bolstered by certain um celebrities like
joe rogan and elon musk announcing they
are abandoning california and going to
texas
there's this assumption that you just
pay a lot less in taxes if you go to
texas and
that is true for people who make a lot
of money
but the reality is that for a lot of
people
the state tax rate is actually higher in
texas
uh when you consider state and local
taxes and there's a really good post
about this
um it's actually someone posted it to
our subreddit but it's a link to
the joe rogan subreddit um and and it
outlines this and i think that
uh it's important to understand that
in some cases when you go from a
so-called high tax state to a low tax
state
you really are paying less in taxes in
many cases you're not there are states
with no state income tax where property
taxes and sales taxes for example are
significantly higher
we've talked before about how you can
also hide taxes
in other transaction fees there are
places where you might say oh the sales
tax is low
and there's a low or no income tax
but every fee associated with uh
driving a car insurance requirements on
different elements
there are lots of different ways in
which living in one state versus another
can be more expensive and
people who make decisions based solely
on state income tax
are often what's the word surprise
they receive a rude awakening when they
realize that hey i'm not paying a state
income tax anymore or not one that's as
high
but i'm paying all of these new and
different things very interesting
analysis i encourage you to look at it
in detail
another post and this this is sort of
like from the news of the obvious and
unsurprising
the creator of that cpac golden trump
statue now admits that it was made
in china um i don't know how many of you
even followed this story but there was
this incredibly cult-like i mean really
disturbingly cult-like
golden trump statue
that was wheeled through cpac the
conservative political action conference
over the weekend which we covered
and aside from it all being really weird
because people were almost like
praying at the altar of this thing
extraordinarily cult-like trumpian
behavior people started asking where was
this thing made this would be really
expensive to make in the united states
and
i guess initially the guy who made it
said it was made in mexico
i don't even know if that's good or bad
but then we ultimately found out that it
was actually made in china
and i i don't even think we have to
comment a lot of the trump campaign gear
for years was made in china while trump
was publicly saying
china's crushing us on this china's
crushing us on that well partially maybe
they're crushing us because you're
giving them your own business
we now found out that the trump golden
statue was made in china not surprising
but predictably hypocritical
join the discussion by joining the
subreddit
at davidpakman.com r-e-d-d-i-t
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign
up for their completely free service at
privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number the privacy app
and the browser plug-in let you give
each company a randomized
virtual credit card number that you
create out of thin air it'll even
autofill the card number with one click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over if i use a virtual credit card
number
you're keeping your identity private by
not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or credit card
info protected
against data breaches and identity theft
and it's free
and like i said you'll get five dollars
to spend when you sign up
at privacy.com slash pacman